hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the world fish
random championship while Magnus cross
and West Lisa were battling it out for
the title of world fish random champion
Yana Comaneci and Fabien Caruana
were battling it out for the the bronze
prize for the third place so this is one
of the games it's the first game of the
rapid so for Class 4 games have been
played Fabi started the match that the
same way he did against Magnus he won
the first game of the classical time
section but then one game was wrong and
the nipple was able to win two games in
the classical time for me so Fabi needs
a lot of ways to get back in the match
that goes without saying
but before we check out the game I would
just like to invite everyone to check
out a beautiful song by a legendary
Grandmaster your hand near Tori the link
to it will be the first thing you see in
the description below its it's a song
about Bobby Fischer well dedicated to
Bobby Fischer but about Bobby Fischer
and Fischer random I was I don't know
when it was made but the the video on
YouTube was uploaded in 2018 and Torre
in the video states that he would very
much enjoy that Fischer's dream comes
true that well that fidei recognizes
that official random should we an
officially recognized event and here we
are covering the first-ever official
world feed a world Fisher random
championship officially recognized by
fetus so I thought it was just a very
nice idea and the song is beautiful I
would listen to it a few times on repeat
it's it's not an original song it's a
cover but still it's it's just very nice
so the first thing you see in the
description below you can even check it
out before watching the game you will
you know nicely get in into the mood for
the official random so for those of you
who listen to the song and got back
congratulations you are an excellent you
know a follower of well suggestions and
for those of if you just want to enjoy
the show
let's go so nipple with the white pieces
opens with f4 we discussed yesterday
it's the same position as Carson and
Cora wanna head in the rapid games where
a knight b3 and just f4 are the favorite
moves here because you're a two point is
a week and also you want to start with
this to attack blacks a week a seven
point and this is what nipple will use
this is a week bone and this is a week
bounine nipple will very quickly develop
his pieces to try and attack those weak
points as you'll see in the game so f/4
already going after the week h7 pawn
Fabi defends it and now tonight the b3 s
of course nipple nipple is expecting a
f5 or f6 that the Fabi will also open up
his light square bishop and now Queen to
g3 again just going for that weak pawn
so Queen to g3 g6 defending and now
efore we have c6 by Fabi Bishop to e3
and now Bishop the c7 and nicely a
developing the bishop Magnus got in
trouble in his game against Wesley for
developing the rush of the c7 but here
it's a it's a different position and
here nepo doesn't mind wasting a temple
as it comes well there's a nice battery
here that will go after the a7 pawn and
a post play now is a 4 a 5 so we have
queenside castle by Fabi and now d3
first now we have King to be 8 and now
Knight f2 d2 are continuing development
with d5 by Fabi and a4 now with the idea
of a 5 if you capture just Bishop
captures an a7 but a 5 is coming so with
D captures on e4 by Fabi now a5 so
Knight to c8 first guarding the a7 pawn
with the night and only now D captures
on e4 we have E 5 by Fabi and here neppo
never doesn't want to wait for captures
and therefore he doesn't want to trade
the dark square Bishop set one so first
f5g captures an f5 e captures an f5 and
now Bishop to d5 just developing the
light square bishop and maybe
considering rook to GA to go after the G
to pawn where you might have some
problems you cannot play G 3 because the
rook is still on h1 so first nipple gets
into a car all the way now I broke Jade
you can always push g3 Bobby goes h5 and
rook to a-1 with the idea of a very
nice-nice rook lift with rook to a 4 so
we have Knight to d7 by Fabi going for
that c5 square not immediately but maybe
c5 maybe maybe he has ideas of pushing
efore and then developing the night over
to e5 maybe even wood upon sacrifice all
depends on what a nipple place so rook
to a 4 it's a very nice square for the
rook covers the entire fourth
also covers the h4 square which prevents
black from pushing the point even
further and also you cannot attack at
the b6 covered by the pawn this is
covered by the knight and the bishop on
e3 so the rope is very safe there we
have a six not allowing the point to be
pushed further with a six and now Bishop
to e2 non-people gets his other pieces
into the attack with Knight to d6 and
here just Queen to f1 very nice
now the Queen Bishop battery goes after
the a sex pawn you might have idea so
just snapping off that that a at a sex
pawn so first c5 by Fabi and now what do
you do here
well capturing on e6 would be a bit too
early
so first rook to h4 by nipple
transferring group over to the Kings
side and now rook the c8 lining up the
rook with Whitney Post King as the
position might open up if for example a
c4 is pushed c4 is captured then for
example to represent b3 could open up
the C file and then black could maybe
have some ideas so rook to d1 first
lining up the rook with the undefended
Bishop on d5 and now Queen to g8
defending the bishop and also
threatening the g2 pawn so Knepper just
pushes g3 and now efore Fabi clears the
e5 square for his night with Knight
captures and c5 the c5 point is under
attack but there's no way for Fabi to
actually defend it so you have to give
it a whack give it up so e for Knight
captures on c5 and now Knights thief I
Fabi brings the knight that deeper into
the position we have neither D to b3 and
now Knight d2 c4 so attacking the bishop
here and here nipple could decide to go
Bishop do you want to keep the tension
going but he decides for a very unique
idea Bishop captures on c4 Knight
captures on c4 and now Bishop to f4
offering a trade of the dark square
bishop and now rook to h7 adding another
defender hoping for characters so the
deodoro can come to the C file as well
but here neppo goes kink to be one and
it's a very important move it's not
really an important move but but it is
the idea is an F once to go Knight to d6
and here he could run into some problem
after Bishop sorry after Knights the e3
with an attack on both the brook and the
Queen and here after Bishop captures you
get Bishop captures on b3 and now after
C captures and now you get two
discoveries as the King is on the same
file as the rooks or at least a recap
Bishop captures and g3 will pick up the
rook after the king moves king we
wonderful captors here okay you still
have a queen f4 check and white will
still be better here but you don't want
it's a rapid game you don't want to over
calculate it so just king b1 first and
it is the more precise move so kink the
a8 Bobby also gets this King to a safer
Square and only now Knight to e6 so here
night to e3 is pretty much pointless as
the King no longer occupies the c1
squared Bishop capture Sonny sex with F
Codd % e 6 now creating a wonderful past
epon and the bishop captures on f4 we
have Queen captures on f4 by favi and
now you could you could well consider a
lot of things you could go for the east
exponent it's not a problem then white
picks up the e4 pawn maybe the Queen's
get traded and then the game continues
but here Bobby prefers f5 it's just uh
he just defends the pawn here but here
nepo finds a very interesting idea he
plays rook to d7 so what do you play
here there aren't a lot of moves you can
play this rook doesn't have a good move
the Queen doesn't really have a useful
move because now you cannot capture
because the rook is hanging if you
capture with the rook then you create an
even stronger pass pawn for example rook
moves quinta c7 comes with an attack on
the on the knight Knight the c5 is
coming if the b7 phone will be
threatened it's just a very awkward
position for Fabi on the other hand
after roof 37 you could block maybe
maybe go Ruby 8 but then just rook
captures Queen captures and Queen
captures an f5 eliminating this point
we're gonna lose this pawn the rook is
under attack you're gonna lose the h5
point you still have your task upon so
this will be winning for NAPA so here
Bobby played the most incredible move of
the game and I don't know either it was
a case of double blindness or or
something either it was the greatest
Bluff ever played but he played rook to
h6 he offered an entire rook to nipple
and well
I have to I had to stare at this for a
while to decide what was going on
because after Queen captures rook there
doesn't seem to be any anything here you
can you can try feeding this position to
any engine it will just be a weird weird
position like even if you there are some
suggestions by the engine Knight e5 rook
b8 I mean those are all useless moves as
black is completely lost
I thought maybe okay maybe e3 if the
threat and something but still you just
eliminate this the defender of the e3
pawn for example drop capture screen
captures on e3 you're just down a piece
and at this point is still gonna become
a queen so it's a really just an a very
impressive move by Fabi and a very
resourceful move you know when two of
the best moves don't work then you play
a move like this and nipple actually
doesn't capture the roof Nepalese East
seven and the nipple was a much better
on the clock I believe nipple was around
at a three minute mark whereas Fabi was
below a minute so this is a nipple just
refused the rook it's really really
impressive stuff and here with with this
move nipple allows Fabi to get back into
the game
so Fabi goes a Fabia should have gone
for four rook to c6 getting a drugs to
the C file trying to create some chances
against the white king he goes rook to
f6 instead and now we have rook captures
an h5 by nipple going for the f5 phone
now Queen to eight attacking the rook
here and now looked a c7 now just
offering a trade of rooks and here okay
if you trade then you get Queen captures
here and then if Roop the c6 trying to
do something with this Queen and c7 then
you just check you have to bring the
rook back and now Queen captures rook
captures rook to h7 the game continues
where white of course is better the the
King is much closer to the to the black
pawns and you can also start pushing
your H pawn and it would probably be
better but
Fabi went for e3 and here's where Nepal
really takes the game he plays the rook
capture Sun c8 Queen captures on c8 and
now just of course you will see the move
Queen captures and c4 congratulations on
spotting it and it was in this position
on move 35 that the Fabia
Khurana resigned the game and this is
like I said the first game of the rapid
section and Fabi did not win a single
game during the rapid section the only
game he won was the first game of the
classical time section here I believe
two games were drawn and two games were
won by nepo so by winning two games in
the rapid and two games in the classical
time section nepo takes the match
without even reaching the double it's
the Blitz format where the final result
I believe of 12 and a half the five and
a half which is which is very impressive
against a player like Fabiana Khurana so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it do check out the link
beautiful beautiful song by by legendary
Grandmaster haenyeo Torre about Bobby
Fischer and facial random it only has a
1000 views so I would really appreciate
it if you guys checked it out it's just
just a wonderful song I'm sure going to
enjoy it
so that's he resigned because you don't
have a move here you're down a piece if
Queen captures then you just promote -
you don't even have to grab a queen you
could grab a rope
White is so much better king a7 you just
go look here threaten mate and there is
no defense against mate here you can
give one check King moves and still rock
day it will be checked you could try b5
to create something for a king to run
away but then you just get rookie 7
mates so still just the console covers
the b6 square so after Queen C for Fabio
resigned and Napo is number 3 in the
world officially in the in the in the
official random chess
congratulations the nipple and also to
Khurana for reaching this far at the top
four players in the world I would like
to thank Marie Sondergaard
hair loss cure 2020 a Gregory breed a
William debryn and Yasha top chief for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think of for watching and I will see you
soon
we're continuing checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and probably
tomorrow we will have our vote on the
next big saga and the do check out the
link in the description below
it's just beautiful so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
first year day